she should pay some penalty for being so
[ __ ] dim this guy
figured it out
a man claiming to be a Russian astronaut
in space allegedly scammed the Japanese
woman into paying for his return trip to
Earth vowing to marry her once he landed
this is from Vice believing this man
would be her future fiancee the woman
paid him about 4.4 million yen about
thirty thousand dollars in five
installments from August 19th to
September 5th the Japanese newspaper
yamir shimbun reported but when his
demands continued the woman grew
suspicious of his intent and reported
him to the police who are investigating
the case as a romance scam local media
reported a romance scam Intergalactic
romance scam dude
dumb Intergalactic romance scam
romance scam Intergalactic dude I I
this is the thing dude scams are are
shitty you can prey on people and make
them scams like I watch this HBO Max
[ __ ] documentary on scammers and
these guys really go out of their way to
make people feel like you know
comfortable and good at giving money and
[ __ ] like that those people uh you know
those people deserve to pay some sort of
penalty or whatever this guy yeah
figured it out she should pay some
penalty for being so [ __ ] dim hello I
am in space I need to get home I need
you know rubles or whatever the [ __ ] the
Aruba is whatever the [ __ ] Russian
money is yeah and four 4.4 yeah oh it's
Japanese she was in Japan
oh my god dude yeah like imagine this
guy just like
If I Only Had thirty thousand dollars
and also how did he find this woman like
yeah here's the thing about the scammers
whatever obviously they're [ __ ]
villains that's [ __ ] service up there
but the people who get scammed was it on
Zoom yeah the don't get scammed dude oh
dude it was dumb ass [ __ ] dude it was
the zoom with the space background
it's just like this he's just like this
doing it like just like like
having the wallet flow so you can't see
his hand yeah he's really just some in
Moscow somewhere you know what I mean oh
my God they suck early and I need five
grand
I need five grand alien allergic to the
end
please need rubles need anything you
need yeah I mean the advice here is any
flat bottom line anybody who emails you
that you don't know no you do not give
them anything information further
further than that the advice is never
trust somebody on the internet period
yeah even someone you do know because it
might not be them yeah yeah yeah yeah
and if they want money no
this is crazy dude how are the cops
going to get him though in outer space
it's hard it's hard so you can turn
Galactic please
like this
yeah he's gonna get away dude
[ __ ] it
so [ __ ] stupid
[Applause]
I mean it's taking it's taking so long
because the space is slow that's the
bullet
oh all right hello
hello
hello hello
[Music]